nouvelles prévisions sur le prix des
aliments encore une fois on annonce une
hausse importante qui pourrait atteindre
3 5 % dans certaines provinces pour moi
c'est mon épée parce que je suis tout
seul mais je sais que pour les gens qui
ont une famille ça n'a pas été évident
c'est sûr que ça se ressent quand on va
faire son épicerie c'est pas ça ne suis
pas avec les salaires camama les
allemands qui connaîtront la hausse la
plus marquée les légumes d'abord puis le
pain les céréales et les fruits une des
explications
le phénomène el niño qui pourrait
compliquer la vie des producteurs du
continent
on achète beaucoup beaucoup de légumes
en amérique du nord or on pense que
s'approvisionner de légumes des états
unis du mexique soit deux de plus mais
surprise on anticipe une baisse du prix
des poissons défoulement et surtout de
la viande à chaque année en fait la
demande pour le boeuf diminue et on
croit on prétend que les des terres vont
vouloir ainsi des consommateurs
réapprivoiser leboeuf dans le fond en
2019 je pense que c'est tout le
mouvement vigan est végétarien c'est une
grosse influence là dessus au personal
match consume pas de viande rouge
au total ces hausses devraient coûter
plus de 400 dollars aux familles
canadiennes sur un budget alimentaire
moyen de 12 mille dollars
on voit la lima comme une bien de
consommation comme les autres alors que
c'est absolument pas le cas c'est
fondamental se nourrir c'est essentiel à
la vie le rcq quoi qu'il faudrait que
l'état sur un bien meilleur contrôle du
prix des aliments de base
le fait que ça augmente sa na pali
salaires eux restent relativement les
mêmes et les personnes qui sont au
salaire minimum n'ont pas suffisamment
de sous pour être capable de couvrir
leurs dépenses alimentaires de façon
adéquate
finalement d'après les prévisions des
chercheurs certaines provinces en tirons
malgré tout relativement bien
alors que d'autres devront s'attendre à
payer une note encore plus salée
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal